[Music]
hi I'm Jeff Lezama and you're watching
hash tag news the ladies dance turn on
vine has hit that Raven here's my
version hit boys ok not doing that again
the big story this week was the
announcement of snap - I'm gonna do my
best to catch you up in under a minute
and if I don't then the boys here are
gonna show you a very embarrassing
little school photo of them we're not
rooting for you you can't do it thanks
guys
here we go timer snapchat sent its users
a super weird video introducing them to
their latest feature that allows you to
send money through the app it's
integrated with square which has a solid
reputation of dealing with people's
money but it's also on snapchat which
doesn't have a good reputation for
dealing with anything now this trend is
exciting because these companies are
trying to make the physical dollar bill
obsolete this would mean no more
physical money it's cumbersome it's not
easily divisible it can be reproduced by
skilled counterfeiters and it has huge
traces of cocaine on it this is a true
fact people let's go back to the main
point here which is that it's on
snapchat that's like doing your banking
and a strip club I'd like to make a
withdrawal do you have an account number
I have my debit card just swipe it you
I'm just reading for myself through
college ok to judge me you could work at
a real bank so not only have you set up
a money exchange and a service known for
receiving unsolicited nudes you I have
to pay for it now - no thanks
but in order to send the money you
literally have to make it rain don't
make sending money fun once I get
started I just can't stop
making it ready and now I'm broke
hey snapchat when do you stick to what
you're good at making photos disappear
and not my money hey guys how to do
oh don't worry girl like it's better and
now for the challenge portion of the
news as suggested by epic kitten fail I
will be delivering the news while
listening to death metal I'm full blast
let's rock grandma's smoking weed for
the first time is the newest and oldest
viral video do the legalization of
recreational use of marijuana in
Washington some people got the brilliant
idea to put three adorable grandmother's
in front of a camera to smoke weed for
the first time ever do it like you mean
it coming to Broadway this season
poppy farts the music cuz you never call
it being of nonsensical ramblings
billowing chain look you have an
interview to the New York Times T
Magazine where they set some pretty
outlandish and pretty insightful things
now we're gonna play great minds in
history or Smith kids what your own mind
thinks sometimes is the thing that makes
you sad great my oh I'm sorry that's
fourteen-year-old Willow Smith 14 I
don't want to be a tree I want to be its
meaning I'm gonna think great mind
that's correct but not Washington so I'm
gonna take away a point when you think
about an apple you also think about the
opposite of an apple that's correct and
the winner is you you're the winner of
knowing Smith kids which is weird
[Music]
my wife just left me and finally
pitch-perfect
to release its new trailer featuring
everyone's favorite German on YouTube
and if they're auditioning for youtubers
I want to audition right now your
grandma would say she was hi and here
are some of our favorites at Ted
marzipan I obscene I said Martha said I
was gonna bake you some cookies but I
stopped it baked good one grandma
escapade said goodbye Steve debate said
so glad I switched out my oxygen tank
for a vaporizer grandma that's probably
not that good for you and that shut up
Nick Nick Nick shut up said move over
Reagan oh grandma's got a new herb on
her spice rack I'll get that one grandma
I'm winking at the camera okay you guys
make sure you like this video if you
want to see some cash money grannies I'm
such a and subscribe for more
entertaining news coverage this has been
hashtag news i'm just osama and i'm
bringing back the choker necklace
watches watch out bye